okay so um I'm coming to you from the UK
international search and rescue Command
Center uh we're situated at the heytase
stadium
um all of our teams are currently in the
center of hate
um busy continuing with their rescue
effort
what does that look like what are they
doing
team successfully rescued two life
casualties yesterday and found a third
so um they're doing damage assessments
so integrating with the local
communities and Gathering the
intelligence from families that know
exactly where their loved ones uh are
situated so we're out there using search
dogs
um search cameras and tools to access
those that we know and confirmed are
still alive of which we are still
finding live victims
that is surprising is it given that it's
more than 72 hours since This Disaster
struck
uh it's it's surprising but it's
encouraging uh the way these buildings
have collapsed uh they leave many
survivable voids within them and given
the time that this happened a lot of
people are wrapped up in in bedding and
such so whilst the people that were
recovered yesterday were very dehydrated
slightly hypothermic because of the
extremely cold conditions here and
they're still alive and with that
encouragement from people outside I
think seems to be keeping them going so
I've just received notice from our teams
out on the ground now they've just
identified another two they think live
casualties so we've had positive hits
from our search dogs of two further live
casualties that we're currently working
on
tell me a little bit more about that if
you would please sir
yeah okay we're in the center of hay day
is the designated detector for us
um we've we've got a team down there at
the moment they're split into two
different sites so we've got a team of
40 people that are currently working to
recover these two people
um they've embedded with some of your
teams down there so we know that we've
got some Sky teams uh nearby on the
ground uh but we're in this we're in the
center of hate where they engage with
the UK team yesterday
foreign
that is I mean almost uh remarkable that
people could still be pulled alive from
this wreckage as you were saying but if
they're wrapped in blankets they uh can
be protected against the coals but what
about dehydration
yeah we had examples uh yesterday when I
was down on the on the ground um of
people that actually just pinned down so
they're trapped they can't just
physically be pulled out but families
are able to get water and food into
these people so as long as they can
maintain that then we should send a
great chance of the dive casualties
being recovered
foreign
how difficult is it to get someone who
is still alive freed from Tangled metal
when you don't know what is beneath
yeah it's very very difficult it's it's
difficult for our crews uh we're still
suffering from aftershocks here so the
already very much damaged infrastructure
it poses a significant risk to us but
we've got our own safety protocols in
place we've got our own Medics standing
by embedded with the teams so that as
soon as we can release people from the
structure we can administer immediate
aid to those Medical Aid to those
individuals there are ambulances running
as you will see all over the city at the
moment and they're actively looking for
casualties to recover